- To those who can overcome the obstacles,
rise up when difficulties arise,
are the ones who win the prize.
Everybody starts at the bottom
and there is no advantage
to starting 10 years ago,
as opposed to starting today.
In fact, it's better
today, than it was then.
Action is determined by your attitude
and attitude is determined by your acts.
- He's an American
businessman, cofounder of Amway
and owner of the Orlando
Magic basketball team.
At one point, he was one of
the 10 wealthiest Americans.
He has an estimated net worth
of five point one billion dollars.
He's Rich DeVos
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules to success.
Rule number five is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, if hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down the comments below.
Put quotes around that as well,
so other people can be inspired.
Also, when you write it
down, you're much more likely
to lock in for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(soaring music)
- You are a part of something
that transcends all the
details of your business.
It's a part of demonstrating
that free enterprise works,
that someone can start
with a $50 sales kit
and build a large business.
You prove it every day that it works
and you prove it by
overcoming the obstacles
that you have to deal with.
There are all sorts of people
that want to break your faith.
Some enter your own family
and sometimes they're just
so-called good friends,
who think you're crazy for
doing what you're doing.
But you see, you have decided
to take charge of your life.
You have decided that you
are going to change it.
You're not going to
wait for the government,
you're not going to wait for some school
or something else to happen.
You are going to change your situation.
That's what free enterprise is all about.
Jay and I decided to do that,
I don't know over 50, 60 years ago.
We started in this kind
of business in 1949.
I was 23.
All I know is this business.
I spent my life at it,
went pretty good,
but it wasn't always easy.
Business isn't, life isn't,
but to those who can
overcome the obstacles,
rise up when difficulties arise,
are the ones who win the prize.
I recently picked up a book
by a Dr. Norman Doidge, D-O-I-D-G-E.
He's a brain guy.
Psychiatrist.
And his study says that I
can confirm to you the power
of positive thinking scientifically
because so many people ridicule
that whole idea of positive thinking.
I can show you positively,
that turning yourself
into a positive thinker
will change your brain
and how it functions and
how you think about yourself
and what you can accomplish.
Now it's been laughed
at and most of my life
and people say, oh that,
that's just wishful thinking.
Well, I don't think it's wishful thinking,
Norman didn't think it
was wishful thinking.
His was all biblically based
and Bob Schuller did pretty good with it.
I did pretty good with it.
Starting at the bottom at Amway
is where ever you are today.
Everybody starts at the bottom
and there is no advantage
to starting 10 years ago,
as opposed to starting today.
In fact it's better
today than it was then.
Our products are better,
our line is better,
our plant is better, it's more proven.
It's a better plan today
than when we started.
And sometimes there are no answers
as to whether you want to be in business
or would like to be in business.
You just got to put year
toe in the water, you know.
If your going to wait
until you know everything,
you'll never do anything.
And you'll always say, well
I got to check some more,
I'm going to and a little more research.
So go ahead, just keep going
and you'll never get in a business.
You're going to go swimming,
you got to get wet, you know.
And then you find the
people that got a hot button
for having a business of their own
and want to do their own thing
and like the chance to
build a big business.
Well, you got to have that dream.
That's why other people
talk about having a dream.
Hell, you got to have a
little bit of a dream.
And then you say, I'll
go out and get customers,
you know I got a chance to
really build a big thing.
I'm going to go out
and get some customers.
When you start something
new it's not easy,
but life is easier when you got a business
and you're making some money,
makes it a little easier.
So, stick with it,
find a way through it,
just find out an answer.
It works folks, this business works
for those who work it.
Now, I want to spend a little time
on a kind of an old subject
and yet it's new in some ways,
but it deals with the fear
of failure that affects all of us.
And I know you've come here with hopes
and faith in your future, but
back there is a little bit
of fear about whether you can do it
or what somebody will say about you.
Sometimes we have people
come to a meeting like this,
who are even afraid to tell their friends
they came to an Amway meeting for fear
of what they will say.
And so we are so driven by fear
that sometimes we never do
anything because we're a fear
of what somebody else will say.
And what happens when you
do that is you give control
of your life over to someone else.
And then they decide what's
going to happen to you,
instead of you deciding.
Now we have the fear of failure,
the fear of what other people will say,
the fear of rejection, the fear of change.
Now the first thing we
must do is deal with change
and learn to accept the fact
that things are changing fast
and so to illustrate how to handle change,
I thought since I hadn't
been here in eight years,
I would give you a little Amway history,
so you would see how we handled change.
When Jay Van Andel and I
started our first business,
we started a flying school.
Now that was a change,
but the important thing is
that neither one of us knew how to fly
and so when you consider
doing something new,
you say, oh, I can't do
it, I've never done this.
We didn't let our not flying
stop us from starting.
We just began and hired instructors
and learned from them.
Actually what it finally
comes down to in your business
and how you run it, is
you first and me second.
Take that home with you,
The first thing you want to
do is help your people succeed
and then you succeed.
Just keep it in the right order.
It's not you succeeding
and then hopefully they come out okay.
It's all about them, not about you
and I think that was the
foundation of our business.
You know we never, Jay and I never talked
about how much money we made
or how much money we wanted to make.
We talked about how big we'd
like to have our business,
but it was never a
personal financial goal.
But our focus was on how
we could enrich the lives
of our people and make them better,
often times influencing
them with our faith as well.
My father was a very positive guy.
You know, you can do it, you
can do it, you can do it.
That was his mind.
And I was like, you know,
people say, oh I can't do that.
He was the one who said yes you can.
He wouldn't accept from
me a no or I can't do it.
He would get on me hard
about even saying it,
even thinking you can't do it.
I graduated as class president finally.
So I had to speak at the commencement
and he helped me put my speech together.
It turned out to be pretty good.
One morning he came up to me
and said, you know you
were a lot better than
that minister we had who
was our guest speaker.
That little phrase,
that little experience
really encouraged me
to keep at it, on the speaking side.
His encouragement to me led me
to build a life around encouraging others.
And so, that's where I've done.
Attitude and action
and atmosphere.
You want to take the correct action.
Action is determined by your attitude.
And attitude is determined
by your atmosphere.
Always put yourself in an atmosphere
where you have a chance to succeed.
Put yourself in the presence
of people who think like you,
who want to get ahead
like you and lift you up.
So not only am I encouraging
use phrases of up,
phrases up encouragement,
but to be an encourager,
but to hang around with
people who do that.
And when you deal with your people
and you bring a new one in,
it's their success you need
and then you get rewards.
That's why people want to
take a lot of money out
of the sales kit and it's
against the law, first of all,
to do that as part of our settlement
with the government here,
that we would not put money
in the sales kit as a profit.
So there's no profit in
the act of recruiting.
The profit comes when you
help that person succeed.
That's a vital foundation principle.
Help others first
and then you succeed.
It's been a long time since
I told stories about my boat,
but Jay and I bought a schooner,
the schooner Elizabeth.
And this is the bell off from it
and it's only important
because the boat sank.
She was kind of a nice little
boat, but she leaked a lot.
That was our first big
sailing experiences,
but we bought it, we went on it, we sank
and have owned many boats since then.
You learn from mistakes.
You got to start with faith
and belief in yourself.
That's something you got to
make it your business to do.
It's from the heart that
we derive our emotions
and our energy to take on
and meet new challenges.
This is a business,
where your heart has to be in it
and you have to believe
that you can do it.
And overcome the resistance
and the negative influence
of others to move forward.
So have a good heart for this business.
And find out what you can do,
most all of you will
discover you can do things
you never thought you could do.
You can advance farther
than you ever thought
you could advance once you put your heart
into believing that you can do that.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Kris Westcott asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it
down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Rich say
that had the biggest impact on you.
What are you going to take from this video
and immediately apply to your
life, your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Bitesize Lessons by Mr. Mo.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word and making
that awesome cartoon
and posting it to your Instagram page.
I really, really, really appreciate it
and hope you're enjoying the book.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- Keep, keep it on, keep on.
- Yeah.
- That's all.
There's always tough
periods in any business,
in any life, in any time
and that doesn't mean anything,
except you got to work your way around it
and work your way through it.
It doesn't say.
You review your plan,
figure out what you might
have done right or different
and then get on with it.
If everybody quit when things
were not quite favorable,
well, then would nobody
would get anywhere,
but if you want to get somewhere,
the best time is when it's bad.
So that while everybody else is trying,
you're working
(audience laughing)
and you've done your business.
(audience applauding)
- [Host] Thank you very much, Rich DeVos.